Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
There was a new House of the Dragon season
2 teaser, HBO and the Showrunner
just released. So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch to talk about.
Whole bunch of Game of Thrones
Easter eggs.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will be doing videos
for House of the Dragon Season two,
just like Season one,
just like the main show.
And there are still a bunch
of other sequels,
prequels, spinoffs
that HBO is working on separately,
like the Jon Snow series
with Kit Harington.
Eventually, we might even get to the point
where we have multiple Game of Thrones
shows on in the same year.
Some of them probably plan
on using for alternate years,
so the HBO doesn't have to skip a year
with no episodes
like they're doing this year.
Of course, I will do videos for everything
that they wind up releasing.
We'll be talking about Game of Thrones
when I'm like 90 years old.
It'll be great.
The new House of the Dragon Season
two teaser comes straight
from Ryan Condal, the showrunner,
where he talks about the five new Dragons
that they're going to introduce
in season two shortly. And
in season 2, you're going to see
five new Dragons.
Notice that he only says five new Dragons.
I'll explain
which ones he's talking about.
But before season one,
he revealed that there would be 17
total before the end of the series
like they already have planned out.
Which of the Dragons are going to feature?
Because there are way more than 17 dragons
that are around
during the dance of the Dragons.
So some of them won't make it to screen.
And if you do a head count,
that means that some of the dragons
we won't see until season
three and beyond.
The five new ones
he's probably talking about are Darren
Targaryen's Dragon two Syrian.
He's the fourth child of Alicent Hightower
in Viserys.
It wasn't featured on screen
as an actor during season one,
but they did reference him in the during
the events of season one.
He was around in the later episodes
after the children had grown up,
but he was serving
as a page down in Old Town
while everything was going on around
King's Landing in Dragonstone.
The place where they reference
Daron Targaryen was later in the episodes
after he'd been born in the opening
credits.
For people who pause to overanalyze
the opening sequence,
which I would recommend doing,
if you're really interested about this,
I actually talk about the changes
that they make episode
to episode in All My House
The Dragon Season one episode video.
So you can go back and watch
the different episode videos
to learn how the intro changed
and what they added to it,
how they changed it for every episode,
just to denote the changes
in the bloodline
episode to episode, like Who died
and who was born.
It's meant to be a 3D family tree
using the ancient Valyrian freehold
structure in a bloodline that starts
with the ancient valyrian freehold up
at the top in the doom of Valyria
with the birth of Aegon the Conqueror.
And it shows you where
the blood of ancient Valeria flowed.
Like, who's related to who?
Who has valerian blood
and who's part of which family line?
Because there are actually three known
family lines
that have valyrian blood in them.
There's the targaryens
that we know about, the Valeria Jon's
that they went
into pretty deeply during season one,
and the third one is how Celtic are, who
we saw briefly at the end of the season
at Rainier as Black Council meeting.
This is Bartomeu's Celtic, Ga.
He didn't control dragons
before the dance of the Dragons,
but anybody with any valyrian
blood in their veins can be a dragon rider
or dragons seat.
And that's what Rhaenyra and Daemon
are looking for.
All the allies they can find,
they can ride the extra dragons
that they have access to on dragonstone.
The next one is probably silver weighing
who's the former
dragon of Alison Targaryen.
She was actually a Jaehaerys' queen.
She died a long time ago and silverwing
has been a riderless
ever since she died.
There's the sheepstealer who's
one of the wild dragons ridden by Nettles.
She's a Targaryen bastard.
There's two other wild dragons
that never officially get writers
because they're too wild.
But people do try many times and fail
to become the writers.
The cannibal whose name such
because he eats so many other dragons
and goes after so many other dragon eggs.
He also tries to eat
pretty much anything that gets within
range of his mouth and gray ghost,
who also never had any known writers.
But all three wild dragons are involved
in the dragon bowels issues.
The Sheepstealer is the only one
that officially gets a Dragon rider.
So just because some of them
don't get writers
doesn't mean that they're inactive
during the dance of the Dragons.
They also said that Baela and Rhaena,
the twins, would have a bigger storyline
in season two with more scenes,
and currently Baela has a dragon
named Moondancer.
She might be
one of the five new ones to debut.
And also if you do a head count
of all the dragons that were featured
in some way
during season one, there's actually 12.
So if Ryan Condal said that
only Nine Dragons
were going to be featured in season one,
he was probably only counting the Dragons
that got a lot of screen time.
So like he probably didn't count vermouth
or which we saw
at the very end of the season.
So, for example, vemithor could be
one of those five Baela's younger
sister, Rhaena, eventually gets a dragon
named morning much later in the story,
as do all of Helaena Targaryen's children
Daemon and Rhaenyra as new
surviving children
that they have together, like Aegon,
the third and Vasari's the second.
But all the babies with Targaryen blood.
The young children
don't actually have their dragons
till either much later in the story
or without getting into spoilers,
they're not threats
during the dance of the Dragons and don't
really figure into the part of the story
that they're doing on the series.
So like I said,
even though Ryan Condal and George R.R.
Martin said that there'd be 17 total
Dragons before the end of the House of
the Dragon series
they're covering right now,
they're actually way more dragons
present at this time than just 17.
They're just only talking
about the 17 of them
that are very active during the dance.
Some of them are still inside eggs
and haven't been hatched yet
because they are given
to new Targaryen babies when they're born
and they just haven't hatched yet.
They confirm the season two release date
would be summer next year.
They're just starting to film this month.
So that means that June or July next year
probably.
My hope is that HBO already soft
renewed the series
for the rest of the Dance of the Dragons,
however many seasons they need
to complete this part of the story
so they won't have any huge year
long breaks in future years.
That feels like an oversight
on HBO's part.
Like of course
it was going to be successful.
Why didn't you renew for multiple seasons
at the beginning?
George R.R.
Martin has also said the plan
for the rest of the series is to spend
about four seasons on the dance,
but they'll only do about four seasons.
And then they treat House the Dragon
like an anthology show and just jump
to a different time period and treat it
like House of the Dragon Season 5.
And that's how they cover Aegon's conquest
or the Blackfyre rebellions later
in the timeline or Dunk and Egg.
Just things that are around
in different parts of the timeline.
For those of you that really want them
to do Robert's rebellion, that could be
a future season of House of the Dragon
with a different cast.
There are other showrunners
writers working on the other non targaryen
focused
spinoffs, sequels and prequels.
For example, Kit
Harrington was the person that came to HBO
wanting to make the Jon Snow sequel.
They've got different people working on
that same thing for the other spinoffs.
I've already done a much bigger
separate video about which spinoffs
they're still working
on, which they've canceled.
There's still around seven of them
that they're currently working on,
so I'll link
that below in the description.
The other big thing in Season
2 is also introducing the Dragons Seeds.
Who are all the people with
any kind of Targaryen blood in their veins
on both sides that the Blacks
and the Greens are looking for
to activate as many dragons as possible,
since every dragon is kind of
like a nuclear weapon.
Probably the biggest,
most famous one in the books is Nettles.
She's actually a velaryon bastard
who grew up in Spice Town,
so it's implied
that she's one of the bastards.
One of Corlys Velaryon's, family members,
if not him himself.
There's Hugh Hammer and Ulf White,
who are both Targaryen bastards
that grew up on Dragonstone
but are just regular members in their army
when they dance, the Dragons picks up,
but because they need all the dragons,
these are like anybody
that has any kind of Targaryen
blood in your veins, any valyrian blood.
Come talk to us. We need Dragonriders.
So whereas before
they would have just been relegated
to a life as relatively low
ranking members in the military,
they suddenly get giant promotions
because they become dragonriders.
There's Addam Velaryon, who's supposed
to be the bastard son of Corlys Velaryon.
But what they might do
is they might change things
and just make this a version of Addam
Velaryon
using a different name,
pretending to be calling his bastard,
and just being a back door for Corlys,
being able to pass driftmark
in all of his holdings to Laenor
what he wanted to do originally
because Addam Valerian in the books
is the person who winds up
riding seasmoke and what bigger twist
would there be than Laenor just coming back
pretending to be a bastard,
having his head shaved
so that nobody completely recognizes
who he is
and just takes back up on his old dragon
like, Oh, hey, sorry for the break.
Sorry I was gone for a little while,
but I'm back now.
There's terraxes.
Baby Joffrey's tiny dragon,
very small, obviously.
Joffrey not going to do a whole lot of
fighting because he's so little.
This is a chart that depicts the lineage
of all the Dragons,
Like where all the dragons came from,
who laid the dragon eggs.
We saw vermithor or briefly
at the end of season one,
but Daemon just rattled off
a whole bunch of names.
We'll see all those dragons.
Some of them are much bigger, much older,
but they all roost on Dragonstone,
which is why Daemon and Rhaenyra
control them
because of the death of Lucerys
at the end of season one.
That's sort of the official beginning
of the Dance of the Dragons.
Like, Oh, it's on now.
So when Season
2 picks up, it's
sort of like a nuclear arms race
with people trying to get as many dragons
as possible.
For the blacks and the Greens.
Currently, the blacks control
an overwhelming majority of the dragons,
though they just need to find a bunch
of dragon riders for those dragons.
And speaking of the Greens, there was also
a cool preview of a brand new Season two
character who will be part of the Greens
faction Alys Rivers that just leaked out.
I might do a separate video for that
at some point soon.
She's referred to
as the Witch of Heron Hall.
She gets up to all kinds of crazy stuff.
She's the bastard daughter of Lyonel
Strong who stays at Harrenhal after
Larys Strong.
Her half brother killed him
and her other half brother Harwin strong.
She winds up becoming the lover of Aemond
Targaryen without getting into spoiler.
She gets involved in some
really big stuff in here and Hall just in
general is a really important location
in season 2.
Daemon specifically spent time talking
about it during their war council meeting.
It's mostly because of where it sits
geographically.
It's this in the central location
that's critical
to controlling the rest of Westeros.
So both sides, the Blacks
and the Greens, want to control.
Harrenhal
If you have any big questions
about what's happening
during House of the Dragon Season 2,
just write them in the comments below.
I will do more bonus
videos as we get more information
and more footage from the set.
My full last was episode
nine finale video will be posting Sunday
and I just started doing
The Mandalorian season
3 episode videos all link
those below in the description.
Everyone click here
for a bunch of new house.
The Dragon deleted scenes and click here
to learn about Cregan Stark and other brand
new season two characters.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.